hey youtubers is Charlie awesome news we
confirm that Grodd is coming back to the
flash in the back half of the season so
I'm gonna explain what's going on there
is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway that's going on right now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss out on
anything so of course most of us knew
that Gorilla Grodd would come back in
some way
there have been reportedly stuff from
the set I want to get too spoilery with
stuff from the set but supposedly
they've already been filming that
Gorilla Grodd episode and it's supposed
to be like a two-part episode that'll
take place on earth 19:00 so I'll
explain like which version of Grodd
we're talking about in what about this
new version of the flash because it's
the multiverse so naturally we're gonna
see other versions of the flash from
different earths Harrison wells right
now at STAR Labs is from earth 19 so it
makes sense that he spent all this time
talking about his earth we would
eventually see it the latest new version
of Earth that we've seen so far is Earth
3 jay garrick's earth or Dawson's Creek
earth however you want to think about it
I told everyone inside like the familiar
if they followed my instructions but I
trypsin so get up trickster is swifty
you do the honor of allowing me to kill
you all
but I'm not alum bomb what do you say we
take in the afterlife big boy looks a
little steampunky in the way the earth
too is kind of Art Deco like they almost
tried to set the different earths that
we visit during different periods in our
own Earth's history so the design
language is different so in the comics
earth 19 is set during the reign of King
George but it's still the 21st century
so you have all the regular DC heroes
but you look at their costumes and it
looks like a lot of their design is
gonna be based on World War 1 era
designs so like the flash here he's
really called the accelerated man nobody
knows who he is his identity hasn't been
revealed yet but it might be Barry Allen
on the TV show like earth 19 Barry Allen
he looks kind of like the Red Baron
running around in a pilot suit so
whatever this two-part story is gonna be
it's gonna involve savat are the
accelerated man in Gorilla Grodd so a
lot of you've asked questions about
Gorilla Grodd versus avatar we know that
Savitt are visits different Earth's ESN
like a herald like a doctor alchemy to
let everybody know that he's coming and
start building followers so sabot R yeah
apparently you've grown powerful enough
to challenge him who is he every story I
ever heard about saboteur is basically
the same sabot always the first man ever
granted speed
then over time he became the god of
motion the fastest of us all before
sabotage Greece's an earth with his
presence
he sends a predecessor to prepare for
his arrival
alchemy we also know based on Harrison
wells that they have their own gorilla
City there so this is not our version of
Grodd that we've been seeing the last
couple of seasons so I'll explain that
more in just a second but this is the
quote from Harrison wells he does
describe when you need a cross gorilla
grodd you have sentient gorillas on your
earth - we do many many yeah so just a
trace gorilla grodd on a TV show
starting with season 1 so we have the
particle accelerator explosion
technically the second time that it's
happened because the reverse-flash came
back in time to kill Barry setting off a
new timeline where Barry didn't become
the flash until a little bit later he
had the red emblem so that happens then
eobard thawne disguised as harrison
wells
creates Gorilla Grodd gives him
sentience via the particle accelerator
explosion and then holds him in reserve
until it's time to unleash him on
anybody that comes up against him like
team flash or general Eiling
so the flash fights gorilla grodd for
the first time we get to see him
cock-block the flashes infinite punch
because remember he is super smart and
super strong and super-quick so he gets
away and then we see him again during
season two when he's trying to create
other super smart gorillas to live with
him because he's so lonely so it's kind
of a sad story but it becomes kind of a
King Kong allegory whereby at the end of
the adventure they send him to earth to
where there is a gorilla city like a
place in Africa where gorillas like this
go live Harrison wells tells them about
it so there's a gorilla city on earth
too and now we know there's a gorilla
city on earth 19 so instead of going to
the gorilla city that we saw at the end
of season 2 we're going to be going to
earth 19 I think mostly just because
they want to do as much new stuff as
possible even though we're doing a lot
of the same types of characters
oh my god
come on how
[Music]
welcome dirt to
Toto I've got a feeling we're not in
Kansas anymore this is amazing they're
just ideas on earth I mean just
Ramon what not as I change or speak for
yourself we want our grandkids to know
we did cool stuff so we get to see a new
version of the flash a new version of
Gorilla Grodd in like a whole different
earth so part of the fun of episodes
like during season 2 and they had the
two-parter when they went to earth 2 is
seeing all the changes in the characters
you love like remember on earth 2 when
he looked at the phone like there was
Batman's name on the phone so it's like
oh my god there's a Batman that he talks
to on a regular basis here we don't know
much about killer frost if she's gonna
be in the episode we've already got like
a relatively human looking version of
her on earth 1 so typically when they go
to other earths they try to do different
versions of characters so if we see
killer frost it might be like a super
glammed up Louise Lincoln looking killer
frost they kind of did her costume when
we did the flash-forward with Cisco but
that was pretty hardcore glammed-out so
if this is like World War one looking
earth and her costume would probably
flow from that design language
some of you have asked about sabot are
biting gorilla grodd the only reason I
think that they would go against each
other is ifs avatar did something to
threaten gorilla City or gorilla kind in
gorilla grodd wanted to protect them
that would create a need for a team up
between Grodd in the accelerated mane
and the flash from our earth but there
was like a brief arc in the comics
whereby after flash rebirth the original
Geoff Johns flash rebirth the reverse
flash poisoned the jungles of the
gorillas lived in so they could be
pulling from that or they could just be
doing something original to the show
because Grodd has usually gone against
team flash but in the interest of new
twist this could be a version of Grodd
that fights with team flash so that just
remains to be seen you guys can let me
know like why would Gorilla Grodd fight
with the flash against avatar for those
of you asking about the accelerated man
though he's only been in the comics
briefly and it was in a separate
continuity it was during Grant
Morrison's Multiversity back in 2014 so
that does not exist in the main DC
continuity so this is the flash riders
gone for some of that really weird
really awesome Grant Morrison stuff
Grant Morrison creates some of the most
interesting characters interesting
stories ever but usually they end up
being like one-off stories off by
themselves like graphic novels that are
relatively self-contained so accelerated
Man Earth 19 flash just showed up during
that Multiversity storyline so you can
read that if you want to I'll explain a
little bit more about that comic book
story when we actually get to that
episode they haven't confirmed which
episodes these gorilla grodd episodes
are gonna be but because they shot it a
couple weeks ago I wouldn't be surprised
if the episodes end up falling sometime
around February like you won't have to
wait that long for this stuff to draw so
make some noise for Gorilla Grodd let me
know what you guys are most hype about
and I will say congratulations to this
week's flash giveaway winner the Boy
Wonder you in a flash ring please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there is a new round that
started with this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
a DC video so gonna be awesome week
there's a whole bunch more comic book
stuff that I'm gonna try and get through
my next DC video will probably be
Superman vs. Deathstroke but they also
just finished Civil War 2 a lot have you
been asking me to do a video about that
a lot of you may have heard that legends
of tomorrow is actually gonna go back
and visit young George Lucas they're
going to quote
save Star Wars so I'll probably do a
video about that in the next couple days
- I just love the idea that they're
gonna go back it's more related to the
Raiders of the Lost Ark than it is the
Star Wars but you can't do young George
Lucas without slipping in some Star Wars
jokes well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for the trailer
for the next episode of the flash and
you can click here for the arrow trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight